[Music]
season three is well underway facing how
are we going bigger better this season
we can't give too many details I will
say is we felt an episode this week that
I think is what it was one of my
favorites yes it was my favorite so far
I've loved all the episodes but this one
was stellar yeah this is so much more to
look forward to it really it's getting
better better better ready is so good
it's gonna be such a good season Kansas
City's been so or like they've welcomed
us with open arms and it's it's it's
gonna be a good one
I will say if people enjoy the diversity
of see I wanted to get ready for more so
people who really felt like well maybe I
wish they would help someone like me
yeah get ready straight a common thread
that holds every human together is that
the cast of queer I dishing on season 3
exclusively to ET I know that so many
celebrities have been reaching out to
you guys justin theroux and a stone any
chance we'll see a celebrity on season
well I will say this much the biggest of
the big of the big of the big of the
most major earthmoving earth-shattering
cameos could maybe happen Barack Obama I
don't know my middle name isn't spoiler
and you need to stop your j-school
pushing is that shattering gonna be very
major and I'm really excited but I also
feel like when I said the j-school
picture that came off like more means I
met were to continue making this world a
better place
oh come here Anthony
on a scale of zero to ten how many
tissue boxes are we gonna need this
coming soon like four tears can you guys
I said I beat my record and then not in
a good way that sounded weird but uh the
person that we were helping cried like
four to five times with me and I was
like oh my gosh every time we got
together they were crying so I guess on
the scale of one to ten we're gonna need
about ten and a happy lemon sit out guys
might need tissues before that to this
year's Emmy very exciting for Emmy
nominations who is going to cry the most
when you guys don't think wow yeah you
won't be able to control it I think
Angie's our crier so I would put my
money on Antony crying the Emmys I'm
still sticking to Jonathan we'll make a
wager okay what would that type of
recognition mean to you guys to me it
would mean that we're giving the world
what we're really looking for right now
there's so much negativity out there
we're bringing hope for Grady and joy
we're bringing acceptance and it just it
just proves to me that that's what the
world yearning for right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]